on the same event that had this panel of
crime writers and they were fascinating
and they were just talking about
different things and they said the thing
that fee they fear most because they you
know they write about crime and some of
their descriptions are very gruesome
what do they fear most the biggest fear
was that the well is dry for ideas I
thought that was really interesting the
well is dry for ideas
yeah all the time I mean I think that
that we all deal with trying to tell a
unique story based so funny section just
goes back and I keep using people's
quotes but I was reading in an interview
that Coppola for instance or Coppola did
last week and he's 80 years old he's
trying to make a big movie and they
asked him they said what makes an artist
as a filmmaker like what as a juvett
advice to young entrepreneurial
filmmakers or artists he goes well you
want to be an entrepreneurial filmmaker
that's one thing but he goes if you want
to be an art an artist as a filmmaker
you know just start off with the one
with the one thesis which is this
there's a one in a trillion chance that
and that this zygote was created that
created this a single individual rather
yourself or any of the other ten billion
people on this earth understand that
everyone has an extremely individual
story no matter who they are and you can
be an artist and I think that goes back
to the idea of the well the well will
never be dry because there every story
is individual every story is specific
and I think you know we we just have you
just as a filmmaker have to have to go
out and fight to find that story it's
not always gonna come to you but there's
always a story there's always an
experience there's always a history that
someone or something has and it's your
responsibility as a storyteller to go
find it and to manicure it and to help
that it grow as if it was a flower or
garden until it finally you know comes
to fruition
so which would you say you want to be an
artist or an entrepreneur filmmaker
entrepreneurial filmmaker because it it
seems like you almost start the days of
the artist it's almost like you almost
can't just be that I mean I'd love to
just be an artist walking around with a
camera and thinking it but you know we
all have to pay we're in but in the end
like I don't know I've never thought of
myself as trying to be like an
entrepreneur and China
you know reinvent the wheel I just want
to tell stories and I hope that those
stories resonate with some people and if
along the way you happen to have be
successful in business that's amazing
we all want it we all want to come from
a more comfortable life than we have at
the moment I don't think anyone I think
even the richest people are always
looking to make their life more
comfortable make their life better
whatever those reasons are but I just I
like you know I think like Queen and the
other two films you know I like I think
I have a predilection I like focusing on
people who don't necessarily have their
stories told not as if like you know I'm
not gonna go to the homeless guy on the
street and be like I'm gonna tell your
story maybe one day but I'm just saying
it's not it's not saying it has to be
extremes all the time but I like the
person you know I like telling stories
about people that in their small worlds
and showing that everyone's world is
really important to them and everyone
has their own individual their
individual evolution so I don't know I
guess I want to be an artist and I guess
I'd love to be sure myself an artist but
I think you know it's business and we're
all doing you know we all we all have
got to do business as well how do you
start a screenplay I mean since you
since you love characters that maybe
aren't mainstream and I am the same way
don't resonate with a lot of like chick
flicks and it's not that this to me I
just I can't identify what it's too
perfect for me and I don't I find myself
getting squeamish like something a
little more of some edges around it yeah
I mean I like broken people cuz I feel
like one as well yeah a lot I like
people were conflicted it's so weird
like how do they scream flames all
different ways I can't tell you the
biggest part of the process you madama
s-- in the world but the empty page is
the scariest thing in the world so it's
just like the way I start writing is
like say I'm a photographer as well so
most of my films that I've written are
based off of an image maybe that I've
taken that's kind of where I start a lot
is someone that I've captured through an
image either the image really has ends
up having nothing to do with the story
it's kind of like there's an image
burned into my head and I start with
that and I allow that to take its
evolution I'm a pretty sloppy writer in
that I just start writing and I let the
story in the character the characters
guide me because I mainly write films
that are seen by a singular POV of the
main character so because of that I kind
of follow that character and I learn
about them and as I learned about them a
plot of vaults but that's kind of how I
start on a film
I'm writing it from the beginning is I
mostly comes from an image and then that
image is mostly gives me an idea for a
character and then I follow that
character and then the world starts to
build and then I rewrite a lot you know
sometimes it will come you know someone
goes hey I might you know have some
money to make a movie I have a small
idea what do you think in that idea
becomes a giant kernel or because a
kernel that pops and suddenly you run
with that idea because there's a real
possibility of making it and you make it
your own I mean that's a big thing I've
learned and also about filmmaking is you
got to be able to sometimes make someone
else's idea your own
and that's a really interesting process
as well and its own right but for
writing with me it's it's the image
comes first and then the character and
then I follow that character and I find
a world and I find a plot within that
characters world and I go on the ride
and I try to be the first audience
member and enjoy that process um I like
to write fast I don't like I never and I
mean this could be us to my own
detriment but I don't spend a lot of
time on a screenplay I try to just write
fast get it out push it out there and
then then go through to start going
through the rewriting process I show it
to a group of people that I trust or you
know or attach somehow to the project
but mainly you know you find yourself
you always need a good sounding board
and it's one of those important elements
of the writing process and of every of
every process of a film is having people
that you can go what do you think cause
like I'm lost and you know kind of
finding that nature of people that can
give you notes and give you ideas and
tell you when you're right or wrong or
too stuck so with Queen was there an
image I know you said you were in a
conflicted place and you had to get it
out but was there an image yeah there
was a photo of a woman on Western Avenue
wearing a leopard skin Pro coat that I
took out of the side of a car and the
film started with an idea of a woman in
a leopard skin coat and was she waiting
for a bus like what was she doing I'm
not sure what she was doing it was
probably not good it was cool but I know
the image I can see it in my head right
now and it's actually funny enough now
next where I took the image was in front
of a church which is now next door to my
office where I write and added himself
so long years later but yeah how ironic
so are really interesting yeah so yeah
it is thinking about but yeah I remember
that
image and from that image but then you
saw it that
just spurned this character and then the
character I pulled from my life and tons
of real-life situations and scenarios
people and then people I had other
photos I take in I took those I wrote
about those characters and but um it's
some of them changed onset like you know
everything the whole writing process is
such an evolution but yeah it really did
come from a photo out of the side of a
car Western Avenue and Holly on Western
Avenue yeah
you